en tanilo suficiente como para acabar
con toda la población estadounidense es
el balance de la DEA tras haber
requisado en 2022
379 millones de dosis potencialmente
mortales Naciones Unidas habla de
epidemia y Alfredo Hernández fundador de
improving lives lo explica para France
24 en este momento no tenemos un control
sobre la situación y los casos de que
estamos encontrando y la cantidad del
uso y la entrada al país nos lleva a
catalogarlo como epidemia alrededor de
109 mil personas murieron en Estados
Unidos en 2021 por sobredosis el 70% fue
por fentanilo y la preocupación aumenta
año a año entre 2019 y 2020 los decesos
aumentaron un 30% en 2021 siguió la
tendencia y las muertes se incrementaron
un 15%. el fentanilo es un opiáceo que
procede de la amapola es 50 veces más
fuerte que la Y 100 que la morfina su
extrema potencia hace que la droga sea
más barata más potente más Adictiva y
más peligrosa se puede conseguir de
forma ilegal cuya fabricación suele ser
en México con químicos procedentes de
China pero también Es legal El fármaco
es recetado por médicos para tratar el
dolor intenso en los últimos años la
justicia estadounidense ha condenado a
distintas farmacéuticas a pagar grandes
cantidades de dinero por su
responsabilidad y aquí hay una cultura
donde en Estados Unidos se espera que
para el trato del medicamento para el
trato del dolor lo que utilizamos
inmediatamente son los opiáceos en el
resto del mundo es como último recurso y
es una cultura que hay que cambiar entre
los doctores el paciente y desde luego
la farmacéutica la administración de Joe
biden es la primera en adoptar la
estrategia de reducción de daños
brindando acceso a tratamiento y apoyo
con el objetivo de combatir la tercera
causa de muerte de Estados Unidos